und natürlich den ministerpräsident von
nordrhein westfalen
herr scholz die fangen
meine damen und herren doch ist das jahr
22 nicht ganz alt geworden und deshalb
möchte ich auch an dieser stelle noch
einmal die besten wünsche für das neue
jahren sie alle übermitteln und
gleichzeitig ist mir wichtig hier dank
auszusprechen viele haben mitgeholfen
das wir über die zeit gekommen sind wir
haben regeln fest gesetzt aber es haben
sich eben auch sehr viele für diese
regeln gehalten ja das genau vergleicht
wird feststellen dass deutschland sicher
in europa zu denen denn dann zählt die
mit die präzisesten und weitreichendsten
kontakt beschränkung regeln festgelegt
haben aber auch mit konsequenzen wenn
wir das infektionsgeschehen betrachten
wir können das sehen denn den
krankenhäusern wir haben auch
entsprechende nachrichten aus vielen
vielen anderen konsequenzen
desinfektions geschehens in den letzten
tagen sehen können und trotzdem obwohl
die lage durch all die maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen haben besser ist als man
befürchten musste wissen wir dass die
neue mikro variante dazu führen wird
dass die infektionen zunehmen werden und
wir werden in den nächsten tagen und
wochen auch größere zahlen sehen als für
sie heute schon erkennen können dass
wissend es ist notwendig dass wir uns
darauf vorbereiten dass die
infektionszahlen steigen werden und dass
wir alle notwendigen maßnahmen ergreifen
genau darüber haben wir uns unterhalten
und verständigt heute in dieser
konferenz aber was mir wichtig ist auch
die ganze zeit über schon zwischen den
tagen und anfang des jahres hat
intensive beratung gegeben
mit hilfe des rk ii mit hilfe unseres
expertengremiums zusammen mit dem
gesundheitsminister beratung der
gesundheitsminister und
gesundheitsministerin es hat intensive
beratung neben der chefs der senats- und
staatskanzleien der länder mit dem
kanzleramtsminister und auch viele
andere haben sich die ganze zeit
beteiligt daran dass wir hier eine
vorbereitete entscheidung haben
klar ist von micon wird uns noch lange
beschäftigen und deshalb kann man auch
nicht eine entwarnung für unser
gesundheitssystem aussprechen wir werden
das muss mit aller klarheit und
deutlichkeit gesagt haben werden höhere
infektionen sehen und es wird auch viele
neue patienten in den krankenhäusern
geben deshalb müssen wir uns auf diese
situation vorbereiten und tun das auch
wir wissen alle was hilft neben den
kontakt beschränkungen überdies noch zu
reden gilt geht es darum dass wir das
impfen und muss dann weiter vorantreiben
der beste schutz vor omikron ist eine
booster impfung und deshalb ist es gut
dass wir unser ziel dass wir zuletzt
gesetzt hatten des weihnachten 30
millionen impfungen zu erreichen auch
tatsächlich erreicht haben und es ist
genauso gut dass wir ehrgeiz sich am
nächsten ziel arbeiten nämlich bis zum
ende dieses monats die nächsten 30
millionen booster impfung zu
organisieren
alle impfstoffe die wir heute verfügbar
haben helfen und sind gut das gilt
insbesondere für den impfstoff von
moderner und den von biketec beide sind
in gleicher weise geeignet zu schützen
und wir haben sehr viele davon zur
verfügung insbesondere was die moderne
betrifft und deshalb bitte ich alle dass
sie diesen impfstoff neben wenn der zur
verfügung steht und sich entsprechend
impfen lassen es hilft gegen die
infektion und durch die unicom
variante das omikron virus und das ist
glaube ich für uns alle ganz ganz
wichtig eine frische impfung bietet
unverändert den besten schutz und das
gilt auch für diejenigen die bisher noch
gar nicht gibt sind auch die erste und
zweite impfung ist ausgesprochen
hilfreich wer sich schon einmal impfen
lassen ist besser vor den
gesundheitlichen folgen geschützt selbst
wenn er noch nicht den ganzen schutz hat
damit den auffrischungsimpfungen dann
verbunden ist was auch hilft das wissen
wir mittlerweile ist das tragen von
masken von medizinischen masken zwei
masten und deshalb empfehlen wir auch an
vielen stellen die nutzung dieser masken
schreiben sie auch in vielen bereichen
unverändert fort es hilft
ich habe schon darüber gesprochen dass
wir in deutschland eine relativ
bessere entwicklung bisher haben als in
vielen nachbarländern auch deshalb weil
wir so weit reichende kontakt
beschränkung bisher festgelegt haben und
deshalb wird das auch für die zukunft
weiter notwendig seien also geht es
darum viele persönliche kontakte zu
reduzieren für private kontakte ist eine
beschränkung auf zehn personen
unverändert gültig und für ungeimpfte
gilt unverändert ein der eigene haushalt
kann sich mit maximal zwei weiteren
personen treffen wir haben unverändert
die strenge regelung von 3g im
öffentlichen verkehr und das gilt auch
für theater und kinos und kulturbereich
zweig manchmal auch 2 gegen tus
wir wissen dass omikron viel
ansteckender ist als die bisherigen
virus varianten die wir im rahmen der
korona pandemie kennengelernt haben und
deshalb sind wir darüber ein gekommen
dass wir etwas was in einigen ländern in
deutschland schon gilt jetzt
flächendeckend einführen wollen nämlich
dass in restaurants und kneipen wo man
ja keine masken tragen kann wenn man am
platz setzt und ist oder etwas trinkt
dann auch entsprechend klare regelungen
haben deshalb ist es so dass wir dort
vorschreiben wollen dass dort nur
diejenigen hingegen können die
vollständig geimpft sind oder ein test
haben bzw
sie mustert es da kann auch dort diese
möglichkeit nutzen ohne sich noch mal
extra testen zu lassen
das ist eine strenge regelung zwei velos
oder gepustet ins restaurant gehen zu
können aber es ist eine notwendige die
dazu beiträgt dass wir besser
vorankommen und dass wir die infektionen
besser kontrollieren können als das
jetzt der fall ist
weil wir uns darüber klar sind dass es
notwendig ist sich auf das vorzubereiten
was kommt haben wir uns auch
auseinandergesetzt mit den quarantäne
und isolierung vorschriften dem
zusammenhang mit infektionen dann
eintreten und deshalb ist klar dass wir
es möglich machen müssen mit einer
situation umzugehen der viele
infiziert werden könnten darum die erste
regelung wer gemustert ist muss als
kontaktperson nicht mehr in quarantäne
darauf haben wir uns verständigt in
enger absprache mit einem beteiligten
die dafür zuständig sind in deutschland
alle anderen können noch zehn tagen die
quarantäne bzw die isolation verlassen
wenn dann keine symptome mehr da sind
und diese frist kann verkürzt werden
wenn betroffene pcr test oder einander
kannten
schnelltest haben auf sieben tage
natürlich gilt für besonders wohlhabende
gruppen wo viele zu schützen sind etwas
anders in krankenhäusern im pflegeheim
kann die kantine oder isolation
sicherheitshalber nach sieben tagen aber
nur mit einem pcr-test verkürzt werden
das sind strenge regeln die aber
pragmatisch sind und die an der
erleichterung bedeuten gegenüber den
heutigen regelung wir haben uns die
übrigen darum und sie möglichst
überschaubar zu machen so dass man sie
gut verstehen kann sie alle bekommen im
übrigen von uns noch dieses schöne
schaubild erreicht und wären besser
öffentlich zur verfügung stellen damit
man das gut nachvollziehen kann was dann
in zukunft überall in deutschland
umgesetzt werden wird alles viel bewegt
in den schulen werden masken getragen in
den schulen wird oft getestet und
deshalb haben wir auch leichtere
vorschriften für die schülerinnen und
schüler festgelegt und dann entsprechend
nach fünf tagen in einem test vorliegt
der schulbetrieb wieder auf rentner sind
man wieder zur schule gehen kann
meine damen und herren das alles sind
weitreichend regeln sie werden dazu
beitragen dass wir uns besser durch
diese situation bewegen können aber wir
müssen wissen dass alles geschieht in
einer lage in der die infektion
zunehmend werden deshalb ist es für uns
auch wichtig dass wir die
wirtschaftshilfen verlängern die wir
heute haben und noch mal gerade für die
gastronomie verbessern auch das ist mit
den heutigen beschlüssen verbunden das
ist mir zum schluss noch mal richtig zu
sagen dass impfen ist wichtig wir
brauchen weiteren im fortschritt es ist
vorangekommen aber nicht so schnell wie
man sich das wünschen muss die impfquote
in deutschland es unverändert nicht sehr
hoch und ich sage an dieser stelle auch
und bin nicht einmal dass ich der
meinung bin dass es gut ist wenn am ende
eine allgemeine impfpflicht steht ich
hab das schon im letzten jahr als meine
position dargestellt der bundestag wird
dazu über demnächst beraten und auch die
länder alle 16 regierungschefin
regierungschefs der länder haben sich
dazu bekannt dass sie für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht sind dass es mit
diesem beschluss jahr verbunden ich
fühle mich da maximal und stützt und das
ist glaube ich auch eine gute grundlage
für die beratung die jetzt im deutschen
bundestag anstehen
gleichzeitig müssen wir für das boostern
werden ich bitte dass alle mithelfen das
hohe tempo das wir insbesondere vor
weihnachten hatten müssen wir bald
wieder erreichen und wenn uns das
gelingt dann haben wir eine chance
besser mit der jetzigen situation
umzugehen als wenn wir das nicht tun es
liegt also an uns wie schwierig die
herausfordern wird die mit dieser
gesundheitskrise verbunden ist die aus
seiner weltweiten virusinfektion
entsteht wenn wir weiter konsequent
unsere kontakt beschränkung durchsetzen
wenn wir weiter konsequent auf impf und
postern setzen dann haben wir eine gute
aussicht so gut wie möglich durch diese
situation zu kommen und möglichst viele
bürger zu schützen
dank als nächstes der vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
nordrhein westfalens ministerpräsident
hendrik ist ja vielen dank erlauben sie
mir zunächst in allen zu beginn diesen
jahres alles gute
für dieses jahr zu wünschen vor allen
dingen gesundheit und dann passt es auch
zum thema coaching beratung die omikron
mutation hat weltweit eine sehr starke
dynamik geben infektionsgeschehen
ausgelöst die
weltgesundheitsorganisation
hat einen neuen weltweiten höchststand
an neuinfektionen gemeldet bei unseren
europäischen
nachbarn steigende infektionszahlen und
auch die krankenhausaufnahmen dramatisch
an auch bei uns in deutschland ist die
sieben tages inzidenz auf mehr als 300
gestiegen und die experten erwarten für
die nächsten tage wochen einen
deutlichen anstieg der infektionszahlen
nikon verlangt deshalb von uns
achtsamkeit entschlossenheit und vor
allen dingen vorausschauendes und
verlässliches handeln die impfung ist
und bleibt ein zentrales mittel der
pandemie bekämpfung sagt der vorsitzende
des expertenrates sollte auch noch mal
deutlich bekräftigt die vorbereitung
einer allgemeinen impfpflicht ist
deshalb teil einer vorausschauenden
pandemie politik bund und länder an
deshalb
bereits im dezember am 21 dezember
gemeinsam gesagt dass unicom die
dringlichkeit einer allgemeinen
impfpflicht
erhöht wir haben diesen beschluss heute
noch einmal
bekräftigt den gern noch einmal
vortragen das auftreten der omicron
variante erhöht die dringlichkeit der
für die mit dem beschluss vom 2 dezember
21 für februar 22 in den blick genommen
einführung einer allgemeine impfpflicht
die länder bitten den bundestag und die
bundesregierung die diesbezüglichen
vorbereitung zügig voranzutreiben und
kurzfristig einen zeitplan vorzulegen
das war der beschluss nehmen wir dann am
21 dezember noch einmal gefasst und
heute bekräftigt haben auch der heutige
bundeskanzler das im november in
aussicht gestellt auch mit der
zeitlichen perspektive anfang februar
ich habe das letztes mal schon gesagt
ist das wort muss am ende auch gelten
wir brauchen tempo und auch für tempo
und auch führungen bei dieser frage ist
darf nicht das gefühl entstehen dass bei
dieser zentralen frage für die pandemie
bekämpfung taktiert wird politik muss da
auch verlässlich sein die länder gehen
davon aus dass bald ein zeitplan für das
weitere vorgehen zur einführung einer
allgemeinen impfpflicht vorliegen wird
die quarantäne bleibt auch bei omikron
ein wichtiges werkzeug um die
verbreitung der infektion zu
verlangsamen
gleichzeitig muss es ein unterschied
machen ob sich menschen durch einen
booster besonders geschützt haben oder
nicht das ist auch ein wichtiger anreiz
für die booster impfung bund und länder
haben auf dieser basis gemeinsam ein
ausgewogenes garantien konzept
erarbeitet wichtig war für uns dabei
dass wir besonders verwundbare und auch
unser gesundheitssystem insgesamt
schützen außerdem bereiten wir uns
darauf vor dass steigende
infektionszahlen auch auswirkungen haben
auf das personal in der kritischen
infrastruktur wir müssen unser land auch
dann am laufen halten wenn mehr menschen
infiziert oder in quarantäne sind dazu
werden pandemie pläne angepasst zu einer
vorausschauenden pandemie politik gehört
auch auf künftige entwicklungen
vorbereitet zu sein der expertenrat der
bundesregierung weist ausdrücklich
darauf hin dass wir in den nächsten
wochen in der lage sein müssen schnell
auf die dynamische entwicklung reagieren
zu können aus sicht der regierungschefs
der unions geführten länder und baden
württembergs ist deshalb erforderlich
dass der bundestag die epidemische lage
feststellt denn die länder brauchen die
möglichkeit
schnell mit zusätzlichen schutzmaßnahmen
reagieren zu können wenn die
infektionszahlen vielen anderen
europäischen ländern explosionsartig
ansteigen sollten natürlich zum schluss
noch ein wort zur
gesamtgesellschaftlichen lage sagen wir
sehen auch im westen immer mehr
sogenannte spaziergänger von querdenkern
corona leugnern
impfgegnern und wie immer sie sich
nennen klar ist das demonstrationsrecht
gilt auch in der pandemie aber die
bedrohung und einschüchterung von
amtsträgern von verantwortungsträgern
oder gar angriffe auf sie tolerieren wir
nicht hass und drogen durch corona
leutner und impfgegner schlagen
mittlerweile vielen
verantwortungsträgern auf allen ebenen
entgegen danke deshalb ausdrücklich
allen beschäftigten in krankenhäusern
kommunalverwaltungen und behörden allen
unseren polizistinnen und polizisten
ordnungskräften dass sie trotzdem ihre
pflicht tun und sich nicht beirren
lassen bestehen und ihrer seite
dann als nächstes die regierende
bürgermeisterin von berlin franziska
gefallen ja meine damen und herren sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler sehr
geehrter herr kollege wüst ich will
zunächst einmal sagen dass ich mich
wirklich herzlich bedanke für die sehr
gute vorbereitung dieser minister
konferenz anhand der dauer- oder besser
der kürze können sie ersehen dass es
hier eine sehr sehr gute vorbereitung
gab die uns ermöglicht hat hier wirklich
auch zügig zu einer gemeinsamen
beschlussfassung zu kommen und das ist
natürlich auch der stringenten führung
und der guten vorarbeit hier aus dem
bundeskanzleramt zu verdanken ich finde
wichtig dass wir an jeder stelle an der
wir maßnahmen treffen nicht nur eine
vorausschauende pandemie politik machen
wir herr wüst das geschildert hat
sondern auch eine maßvolle pandemie
politik die eben sich an der
nachvollziehbarkeit an der
verständlichkeit von maßnahmen aber auch
an der verhältnismäßigkeit von maßnahmen
orientiert denn es ist ganz klar jede
einschränkung die wir zusätzlich treffen
muss abgewogen werden mit den
einschränkungen der freiheitsrechte die
unseren bürgerinnen und bürger haben und
das haben wir sehr verantwortungsvoll
gemacht es geht darum dass wir mit der
omicron variante eine zusätzliche
verstärkung der situation der
schwierigkeiten der absehbar hohen
infektionszahlen haben auf die wir
reagieren müssen und deshalb ist es auch
vertretbar dass wir heute zu weiteren
schritten von beschränkungen gekommen
sind die aber nicht nur auf der einen
seite eine erschwernis auferlegen
sondern auf der anderen seite auch hilfe
und unterstützung gewähren und ich will
dass an zwei beispielen klar machen wir
haben eine entscheidung getroffen die
gastronomie hier mit 2g plus
deutschlandweit zu belegen das gleiche
gilt ja auch für kulturveranstaltungen
für andere veranstaltungen die nach
hygiene rahmen konzepten der länder
laufen und damit noch zugang ermöglichen
dieses zweig plus ist im vorfeld in der
diskussion der letzten monate immer
wieder auch mit sorge betrachtet worden
von den gaststätten verbänden aber unter
dem aspekt dass wir diskutiert haben
dass das plus das testen beinhaltet wir
haben hier heute eine entscheidung
getroffen die das plus in 2 reiche teilt
nämlich einmal mit dem test und zum
anderen mit dem status des geburtsdaten
und das finde ich seine möglichkeit
tatsächlich hier auch das maß voll
umzusetzen
wir bewegen uns ja überall in
deutschland auf die richtung 50 prozent
gebucht hatte das bedeutet die hälfte
der bevölkerung wird in sehr absehbarer
zeit in wenigen tagen gebucht sein wird
dann also ohne test auch die gastronomie
kulturveranstaltung andere orte die mit
der zwecks zweig plus regel belegt sind
auch besuchen können das ist ein
zusätzlicher anreiz für das boostern
dass es ein gewünschter anreiz den wir
ganz klar auch wollen denn es ist
einfach ja auch erwiesen dass diejenigen
die gepustet sind sollten sie dennoch
erkranken deutlich mildere
krankheitsverläufe haben und deswegen
muss unser ziel sein sowohl die
impfquote insgesamt bei den ersten zwei
impfungen aber auch die booster quote
hoch zu bringen ich kann ihnen für
berlin sagen dass wir da auch noch mal
jetzt zusätzlichen schub reinbringen
durch eine verstärkung der impfkampagne
in drei feldern das erste feld ist das
thema kritische infrastruktur mit
besonderen im straßen in den impfzentren
für polizei feuerwehr für wasserwerks
mitarbeiter zum beispiel dieses ist ein
wichtiges feld das wir da unsere
kritische infrastruktur schützen
allein dadurch dass wir sie mit einem
sehr weitgehenden und flächendeckenden
impfschutz auf versehen der zweite
bereich ist und da sehen wir die erfolge
die wir beim kinder impfen auch
verzeichnen konnten dass wir auf das
familien impfen ausweiten dass wir also
ganz klar sagen nicht nur die kinder
sondern die eltern werden gleich mit
geimpft das hat guten anklang gefunden
berlin ist mittlerweile auf platz eins
beim kinder impfen und ich glaube dass
wir wenn wir das zusammen denken mit den
familien mit angeboten vor ort wir da
auch noch mal eine große chance haben
die quote auch höher zu bringen damit
verbunden ist der dritte bereich der des
aufsuchenden impfens im sozialraum in
gebieten wo wir sehen dass die impfquote
noch nicht so gut ist und ganz klar auch
die zusammenarbeit mit multiplikatoren
vor ort egal ob das integrationslotsen
stadtteilmütter andere sind das
aufsuchende impfen im sozialraum für
menschen die wir bisher noch nicht
erreichen konnten ist ein wichtiger
punkt um dieses weitere 30 millionen
ziel zu erreichen und natürlich sind wir
alle im länder kreis dazu fest
entschlossen dass wir hier dieses
bundesweit vorgegebene ziel auch mit
unseren anstrengungen in den ländern
entsprechend erreichen wollen wir haben
uns auch dazu bekannt dass wir und das
ist im vorfeld immer wieder auch in der
diskussion gewesen alles dafür tun
wollen die schulen entsprechend offen zu
halten die kinderbetreuung auf der einen
seite zu sichern aber auch eben den
kinderschutz den gesundheitsschutz über
die beschulung über die angebote zu
gewährleisten dass es auch wichtig um
die versorgung in der bevölkerung
aufrechtzuerhalten den menschen brauchen
gute kinderbetreuung damit sie ihrer
arbeit nachgehen können und deswegen ist
es wichtig dass wir hier den
schulbetrieb auch das stand gar nicht
mehr im beschluss zur debatte weil das
eine selbstverständlichkeit ist dass wir
hier an dieser stelle eben bei uns auch
verständigt haben lassen sie mich noch
zum impfpflicht sagen wir haben darüber
eine diskussion gehabt einerseits das
bekenntnis aller 16 bundesländer zu
einer allgemeinen pflicht aber
andererseits auch die anerkenntnis der
tatsache dass das jetzt im deutschen
bundestag liegt dass es noch im jahr
neuer eine orientierungs debatte dazu
geben würde und dass dann das
gesetzgebungsverfahren im deutschen
bundestag auch einsetzt das braucht die
zeit für die notwendigen demokratischen
prozesse und dieser zeitplan der er in
zukunft auch vorgelegt wird muss eben
auch würdigen dass dieser prozess für
dieses jedoch sehr gravierende thema
auch eine gesetzgebung zeit einfach auch
benötigt um dann in kraft zu treten für
über 80 millionen menschen wir haben
darüber hinaus und das ist mir sehr
wichtig weil es auch eine initiative aus
berlin war im bereich der wirtschafts
hilfen noch mal einen zusätzlichen punkt
setzen können das glaube ich ist sehr
wichtig finden wir auf der einen seite
zusätzliche beschränkungen auferlegen
oder zusätzliche regeln
und kontrolle notwendigkeiten da muss
auf der anderen seite auch das signal
ausgehen dass es unterstützung gibt und
dieses signal geht heute an die
wirtschaft die neue überbrückungshilfe 4
wird entsprechend auch noch mal
angepasst und es ist mir sehr wichtig
das haben wir immer wieder gehört vom
einzelhandel auch von der gastronomie
wenn zusätzliche kontrollen jetzt
notwendig sind um diese regeln
einzuhalten dann bedeutet das für die
einzelnen betriebe für die einzelnen
wirtschaftsunternehmen einen aufwand was
personal bei sachkosten angeht und ich
begrüße es sehr dass hier auch die
initiative die auch durch berlin mit
eingebracht worden ist dass eben diese
fixkosten bei den
entsprechenden überbrückungshilfen
wasser und personalkosten angeht
berücksichtigt werden dass es da eine
zusage vom bund gibt und außerdem haben
wir uns auch sehr gefreut und begrüßen
dass das der antrags- start der
überbrückungshilfe und auch die aus
zahlungsmöglichkeit von
abschlagszahlungen heute hier als signal
an die länder durch den bund gegeben
wurde und natürlich werden wir jetzt von
länderseite alles dafür tun dass diese
maßnahmen zügig umgesetzt werden und
dass wir auch maßnahmen ergreifen um
eventuellen missbrauch entgegenzuwirken
aber denen die es brauchen denen die das
anrecht darauf haben auch zügig diese
hilfen zukommen zu lassen so weit von
meiner seite
vielen dank dann habe ich schon eine
ganze reihe von fragen ich fange mit
moores freude und danach michael fischer
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler haben mir
scheint die regelung des frei testen
durch schnelltests relativ riskant wir
wissen ja dass die schnell dass die auf
dem markt sind die omikron variante
schlechter erkennen als noch andere
varianten
und das gilt grundsätzlich auch für die
zertifizierten tests warum geht man
nicht auf nummer sicher und sagt frey
testen nur mit pcr test
das ist sehr sorgfältig mit einem
experten experten diskutiert worden die
regelung ist aber von allen dann auch
für die geeignetste und am einfachsten
umsetzbare gehalten wurden und wir
glauben dass diese schnelltests auch
eine ausreichende sicherheit bieten
herr bundeskanzler
ministerpräsident wies gerade nochmal
einen konkreten fahrplan für die
einführung der allgemeinen impfpflicht
von der bundesregierung gefordert sie
selbst haben im vergangenen jahr anfang
februar oder anfang märz als ihre
wunschtermine für einen kraft treten
genannte moment sieht es ja nicht danach
aus dass der bundestag zügig also noch
im januar entscheidend wird deswegen
meine frage glauben sie dass spätestens
anfang märz noch zu halten sein wird für
das inkrafttreten der
allgemeinen pflicht werden sie einen
konkreten fahrplan
vorlegen und werden sie sich in den
nächsten wochen auch stärker aktiv in
die debatte einschalten
aus der opposition wird ihnen ja auch
vorgeworfen an dieser stelle zu wenig
führung zu zahlen
ich habe ja dafür gesorgt dass wir in
deutschland jetzt über eine allgemeine
impfpflicht diskutieren und das ist dass
ein konsens gewordenes ich bin sehr froh
dass ich und die regierungschefin den
regierungschefs der länder einig sind
dass das ein guter und notwendiger
schritt ist und jetzt liegt der beratung
im deutschen bundestag bin mitglied des
deutschen bundestages werde für eine
solche pflicht stimmen und auch physiker
und im übrigen ist es so dass ich davon
ausgehe dass wenn die gräben des
deutschen bundestages jetzt wieder
zusammentreten
zum jahresanfang auch der zeitplan
definiert wird in dem die beratung
stattfinden dass es bei einem so
weitreichenden eingriff glaube ich eine
angemessene vorgehensweise und ich habe
großes vertrauen darin dass die
abgeordneten eine kluge weise und auch
aus meiner perspektive richtige
entscheidung treffen werden
dann als nächstes kristina dunz und im
anschluss andreas kienast
es kanzler wir saßen hier schon vor
einem jahr und hatten dann mit der delta
variante zu tun jetzt haben wir mit der
omicron variante zu tun
vor einem jahr ist nicht wirklich klare
kante gezeigt worden jetzt wieder nicht
wie wollen sie den menschen die sorge
nehmen dass wir 2 23 mit einer anderen
variante zu tun haben und an herrn wüst
und frau gefeiert der bundeskanzler hat
immer wieder betont die gesellschaft sei
nicht gespalten darüber kann man
streiten
relativ deutlich ist wie gespalten die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zumindest
heute wahr indem sie doch mit sehr
unterschiedlichen forderungen in das
treffen mit dem bundeskanzler gegangen
sind wie wollen sie in einem wahljahr
mit vier landtagswahlen der gesellschaft
vor leben den menschen vorleben dass
auch die politik geeint ist um corona zu
überwinden
schon dann frage zunächst mal sind
sehr konsequent der entscheidungs froh
und das hat auch konsequent sind gehabt
im realen geschehen wenn sie die
entwicklung in deutschland vergleiche
mit unseren nachbarländern
dann sehen sie erstens dass wir die
weitreichendsten kontakt beschränkungen
im größeren vergleich festgelegt haben
es gibt an der einen oder anderen stelle
weitergehende aber insgesamt waren wir
diejenigen die schnell und zügig solche
beschränkung festgesetzt haben und ich
das jetzt ja auch weiter tun auf die
haben wir uns allerdings sehr
einvernehmlich verständigt das heißt das
papier das sie heute sehen ist eines das
sehr sorgfältig zwischen den tagen und
anfang des jahres entstanden ist und der
beteiligung aller die verantwortung
tragen und darum hat es heute auch eine
kurze und zügige beratung gegeben es
gibt also einigkeit in der deutschen
politik über das was als nächstes zu tun
ist und ich glaube das ist auch eines
der geheimnisse dafür dass wir diesen
schritt so gehen konnten und das wird
auch in der zukunft so sein im übrigen
haben wir in deutschland eine zweite
klare konsequenz gezogen nämlich dass
wir sehr früh damit angefangen haben zu
mustern und auch sehr weit
fortgeschritten sind meines erachtens
sind wir unverändert in europa wohl das
land mit dem größten fortschritt beim
boostern in der europäischen union und
das soll auch so bleiben indem wir das
mit großem tempo jetzt fortsetzen
und beides zusammen die kontakt
beschränkung die wir ergriffen haben und
im übrigen
das was wir jetzt mache im blick auf
info und muss dann werden wir einen
gemeinsamen weg beschreiten diese krise
zu bewältigen
darauf können sich alle verlassen also
meine analyse ist wir handeln gemeinsam
und das ist auch unsere verpflichtung
die wir gegenüber den bürgern und
bürgern haben
vielen dank auch von mir für ihre frage
wenn man unterstellt dass mit dem wort
spaltung der gesellschaft gemeint ist in
zwei gleich große teile dann bin ich
ganz beim bundeskanzler und sehe das
genau wie er dass wir das nicht haben
wir haben eine ganz ganz große mehrheit
von menschen die diese pandemie auch mit
ihren eigenen beiträgen so schnell wie
möglich hinter sich und hinter uns allen
lassen möchte die dafür einschränkungen
kaufen die sich an regeln halten die
sich impfen lassen die sich boostern
lassen sie sich zweimal geimpft haben
dreimal die sicher viertes mal werden
impfen lassen wir haben eine minderheit
das alles ablehnen und ich finde unsere
aufgabe ist dafür zu sorgen dass die
ganz ganz große mehrheit nicht immer
wieder hinnehmen muss einen wechsel von
lockerungen und lockdown und immer
wieder während
freiheitseinschränkung das mache ich das
sagen darf das war nur ihrer einleitung
sie können auf eine andere spaltung
hinaus wir haben sehr viel einigkeit in
der pandemie bekämpfung zwischen bund
und ländern auch heute das ist wichtig
denn die einigkeit auch das konsistente
umsetzen und gemeinsam vortragen ist am
ende erfolgsrezept in unserem föderalen
land ist ja auch als mpk vorsitzender
wichtig beiträge zu leisten dass das an
möglichst vielen themen gelingt vieles
in den letzten sitzungen ja auch auf der
fall gewesen ist es gibt an der einen
oder anderen stelle ein dissenz mir
persönlich ist sehr wichtig den versuch
zu machen sehr vorausschauend zu agieren
die lehren zu ziehen aus dem was wir
jetzt in zwei jahren pandemie erlebt
haben wir sind an der schwelle zum
dritten pandemie ja sie haben es richtig
beschrieben wir wollen nicht an der
schwelle zum vierten pandemie ja wieder
die gleichen probleme haben
deswegen haben wir heute darüber
diskutiert welche konsequenz mann aus
dem appell des expertenrat sich darauf
vorzubereiten sehr schnell in den
nächsten wochen agieren zu müssen unter
umständen man daraus zieht das ist aber
an in einer solchen situation in der wir
gerade stehen in der manches ungewiss
ist auch nicht völlig überraschend und
auch normal und dann ist es gut dass wir
das so tun wie wir es heute getan haben
aber an vielen anderen punkten eben
einigkeit haben diese große einigkeit
hält auch in distanz an der einen oder
anderen frage aus
ja ich kann dann zu ergänzen einen
meinem kollegen hin willst nur zustimmen
natürlich ist es so dass wenn man eine
schwierige politische und
gesellschaftliche frage zu bewältigen
hat das auch mit intensiven diskussionen
um einen guten weg verbunden
aber ich kann ihnen sagen am ende sitzen
wir drei hier und haben einen
gemeinsamen weg innerhalb sehr kurzer
zeit verabredet hinter dem wir aufstehen
können und den wir auch in unsere länder
tragen und wo wir darauf hinwirken
werden dass die umsetzung zügig passiert
wir werden alle in den nächsten tagen
die entsprechenden notwendigen kabinetts
und parlaments zu fassungen haben um
diese maßnahmen so zügig es geht um zu
setzen und auch vor allen dingen gut und
verständlich an unsere bevölkerung zu
kommunizieren denn das ist ja ganz
entscheidend das war auch bei den
quarantäne regeln die jetzt getroffen
worden sind einen ganz handlungs
leitender punkt dass alles was wir hier
tun verständlich und nachvollziehbar
sein muss und die sieben tage regelung
mit eben der entsprechende möglichkeit
der freie testung für alle in der
entsprechenden über sich diese jetzt
hier bekommen haben das ist eine klare
einheitliche regelung zu der wir uns
alle verständigt haben dass es bei der
komplexität der lage schon eine große
leistung und insofern würde ich gerne
wirklich sehen wollen was hier heute an
einigkeit geschafft worden ist in einer
sehr kurzen sehr konstruktiven sitzung
und natürlich zu den punkten über die
wir diskussionsbedarf haben werden wir
auch weiter sprechen und wir haben ja
auch verständigt dass wir und im januar
auch hier wieder zusammenfinden um dann
auch wieder zu bewerten wie sind die
maßnahmen ist die wirkung und daraus
dann schlüsse für die weitere arbeit zu
ziehen aber ich finde wir sollten jetzt
nicht eine spaltung herbeireden die so
einfach nicht da sondern es gibt eine
konstruktive zusammenarbeit und das
ablegen und diskutieren über den besten
weg
fortgeschritten sind beim lesen des
textes betreffen und 2024
als nächstes andreas killers danach
andreas andreas kienast vom zdf und
danach andreas rinke von reuters herr
bundeskanzler sie haben jetzt immer
wieder betont wie wichtig ihnen die
einigkeit in der deutschen politik ist
jetzt hat herr wüst namens der
unionsgeführten länder ein weiteres mal
gefordert die epidemische lage wieder
einzuführen was würde es schaden wenn
sie den wunsch erfüllen im augenblick
ist es so dass alle dinge die jemand
umsetzen möchte und auf die wir uns hier
verständigt haben von den gegenwärtigen
gesetzen umgesetzt werden können
herr bundeskanzler sie haben eben noch
mal ausdrücklich auch für den moderner
impfstoff geworden ist das ihrer meinung
nach ein grund das mangelnde vertrauen
von vielen bürgern offenbar in diesen
impfstoff warum die impfkampagne im
moment etwas lernt oder haben sie eher
das gefühl dass die bundesländer ihre
aufgaben bei dieser impfkampagne noch
nicht ausreichend gemacht haben und eine
kurze zweite frage weil wir bei allen
varianten erlebt haben dass auch omikron
jetzt sich wieder zwischen ländern hin
und her verbreitet sehen sie auf
eu-ebene noch einen stärkeren
abstimmungsbedarf damit dass
möglicherweise bei der nächsten variante
etwas stärker eingedämmt werden kann
wir haben hervorragende impfstoffe das
gilt für alle die in deutschland
eingesetzt werden und demnächst kommt ja
noch einer dazu der klett diejenigen
überzeugt die mit den bisherigen
impfstoffen etwas skeptisch waren da
kann ich nur sagen wer auf den richtigen
impfstoff gewartet hat jetzt kann er
sich impfen lassen er ist damit kann ihm
nutzen dass es doch eine gute sache und
wir haben zwei sehr moderne impfstoffe
moderner und
von den beiden unternehmen und die sind
beide hervorragend und ich kann alle nur
dazu auffordern dass sie die
möglichkeiten die sie haben nutzen
vielleicht darf ich den satz noch sagen
wer eine möglichkeit hat sich impfen zu
lassen sollte da nicht hingehen sondern
eher hinrennen das ist jetzt etwas was
in diesem monat geschehen soll das gilt
fürs impfen das gilt auch für das
boostern es trägt dazu bei dass man sich
schützt vor den gefahren der infektion
und gerade was die neue virus mutationen
betrifft was omikron betrifft ist völlig
klar dass sogar ein einfacher impfschutz
schon ein profilen konsequenzen schützt
und das sieht man besonders gut
geschützt ist wenn man drei mal kämpfte
ist mit der auf rasche impfung und wenn
man dann zweimal beim tec hat und das
dritte mal moderner kriegt ist das ein
ganz großartiger weg und es gibt auch
welche die haben ist das produkt von
astra zenica bekommen dann haben sie
beim text genommen und dann kommt als
drittes moderne und das ist genau gut
europa muss zusammenarbeiten in dieser
frage wir haben das ja auch miteinander
diskutiert beim letzten zusammentreffen
der regierungschefs in europa im
europäischen rat das werden wir auch
weiter tun ich glaube das bewusstsein
dass man nicht gegeneinander somit ein
andere die dinge so hinbekommen kann ist
gewachsen
in der küche nach einer deutschen welle
und danach dann ihr vorschlag von der sz
herr bundeskanzler sie haben nicht
geimpften empfohlen sie sollen jetzt zur
impfung rennen der französische
präsident hat viel deutlichere worte
neulich gefunden was er von nicht impfen
hält worauf müssen sich denn nicht
geimpfte in deutschland gefasst machen
und angesichts der brisanz der lage was
ist denn ihre haltung zu der situation
in kasachstan vor allem dem schießbefehl
und der präsenz russischer truppen dort
steilen kurve aber okay also erstens wer
nicht geimpft ist
gefährdet sich selbst
denn das wissen wir dass diejenigen die
ungeübt sind eine große gefahr laufen
dass sie von der infektion erreicht
werden und dadurch dass sich die neue
variante sogar noch schneller überträgt
wie wir an den zahlen unserer
nachbarländer sehen können muss jeder
davon ausgehen und jede die sich nicht
hat impfen lassen dass die infektion sie
bald erreichen wird und das ist dann für
einige davon ein hohes gesundheitliches
risiko denn das was man an der einen
oder anderen stelle hört dass es nicht
so gefährlich sei stimmt nicht die
infektionsgefahren und etwas geringer
aber sie sind groß genug und deshalb
müssen wir alles dafür tun dass
möglichst viele sich
schützen indem sie sich impfen lassen
das ist die einzige anfängt die man
darauf vernünftigerweise geben kann im
übrigen ist es so dass wir klare
position haben wir wollen
rechtsstaatlichkeit überall schützen wir
rufen dazu auf dass es keine gewalt gibt
und das gemeint auch unterbleibt und
selbstverständlich gilt das auch dafür
dass es keine gewalt ging war wenn man
bürger geben sollte also insofern
befinden uns da einen großen eingang mit
denen das sie von der europäischen union
von der bundesregierung und von mir
hören und von vielen anderen der welt
die sagen bitte kommt zurück zu einer
friedlichen bei teilen wegpunkt im land
herr bundeskanzler sie haben auf die
erfolge der bisherigen maßnahmen
verwiesen sind sie denn überzeugt dass
deutschland ein rasanter anstieg wie in
anderen ländern aufgrund der omicron
variante erspart bleibt oder fürchtet
sich nicht vielleicht auch dass diese
entwicklung nur einfach ein bisschen
später eintritt und zur frage nach der
epidemischen lage haben sie gesagt im
augenblick könnten alle maßnahmen
getroffen werden die zu treffen sein
können sie das auch für die zukunft
garantieren und können sie auch
garantieren dass dann eben auch in der
ausreichenden geschwindigkeit diese
maßnahmen getroffen werden vielen dank
zur zweiten frage zuerst
ja es wird immer schnell entschlossen
gehandelt werden und das wird auch immer
schnell und entschlossen gehandelt
werden können alles was notwendig ist
wird gemacht und es wird keinen
zeitverzug in diesen angelegenheiten
geben
und dass wir konsequent handeln können
haben wir ein grad gezeigt haben mit
ihrer ersten frage hier darauf
hingewiesen dass das infektionsgeschehen
in deutschland sich im augenblick nicht
ganz so dramatisch entwickelt hat wie in
den nachbarländern und das ist eindeutig
auch darauf zurückzuführen dass wir so
konsequente schnelle zügige und
entschlossene maßnahmen ergriffen haben
und deshalb ist auch richtig dass die
gemeinsamen beschlüsse die wir heute
fassen weiter schnell zügig und
entschlossen sind und zum beispiel mit
der weiteren festlegung dass jetzt in
allen restaurants in kneipen bars
überall
zweig plus gilt das nur bewusst hatte
von dem testen befreit sind gehen wir
diesen einen weiteren schritt das ist
doch sehr weitreichend wenn man das in
das gesamte setting der maßnahmen ein
reifen die wir bereits ergriffen haben
nein
ich kann nicht ausschließen dass es
nicht zu einem
erheblichen anstieg der infektionen in
der nächsten zeit kommt wir gehen eher
davon aus dass es zu einem anstieg kommt
wie groß sein wird das können wir nicht
vorhersagen weil wir ja auch so viele
maßnahmen ergriffen haben und die ihre
wirkung haben dass boost das impfen die
ganzen kontakt beschränkungen die wir
gemacht haben wie wir jetzt sehen und
jetzt ist es eine rechnung mit
unglaublich vielen variablen wie sehr
sich der schnelle fortschritt beim
boosten auswirkt ist sehr sich der
fortschritt bei der impfkampagne
ausführt wie massiv die
auswirkungen sind von unseren
weitreichenden kontakt beschränkungen
die wir insbesondere für ungeimpfte
haben und die wir jetzt ja nochmal
verschafft haben handick zum beispiel
auf die zwei gehen plus regelungen für
restaurants
das kann keiner vorhersagen aber wir
sollten davon ausgehen dass es doch zu
höheren infektionszahlen kommt und zwar
auch zu solchen die
viel zu groß sind im hinblick auf das
was wir gerne sehen wollen also deshalb
haben wir ja diese entscheidungen
getroffen und deshalb nochmal dem aufruf
lasst euch kämpfen erst durch boostern
das hilft
von bloomberg und dann noch melanie
amann von spiegel ich möchte direkt
daran anschließen also
die die entwicklung ist ja recht
dynamisch im moment und am 24 wollen sie
sich dann erneut zusammensetzen was ist
denn das kriterium dafür dass dann
eventuell dann auch noch weitere
maßnahmen ergriffen werden oder eben mit
dass man davon absieht geht es dann in
richtung der der booster impfungen oder
auch muss dann letztendlich die das
infektionsgeschehen rückläufig sein ich
bin sehr froh dass wir zum beispiel das
expertenebene um haben dass wir die
guten beratung durch das lka haben dass
wir uns alle miteinander ständig
besprechen das müssen sie sich schon so
vorstellen dass hier ständig kontakte
stattfinden die ministerpräsidenten das
gibt zusammentreffen des bundeskanzlers
mit den regierungschef den
regierungschefs der länder heute war ja
nur praktisch die beurkundung eines ganz
intensiven diskussion so ein konsens
prozesses in dem wir auch die probleme
und die herausforderung sorgfältig
besprochen haben und so muss das aus
meiner sicht auch sein so wird das in
der nächsten zeit auch sein wir werden
die lage ganz genau beobachten wenn er
es zu tun es wird sofort gehandelt darf
können sich alle verlassen da wird es
nichts geben was wir nicht tun weil wir
irgendwie
es aufschieben weil wir
da zweifel haben ob man das sich trauen
sollte doch das wird dann gemacht werden
aber was dann endlich ist das kann
keiner richtig vorhersagen deshalb
müssen wir das genau betrachten ich habe
eben die vielen varianten gesagt und das
sind nur einige die einfluss haben auf
die reale entwicklung des
infektionsgeschehen wir wissen dass wir
das was man heute sagen kann dass es
richtig ist alles unternommen haben das
ist sehr viel
aber wir können erst wenn wir die
entwicklung weiter sehen gucken welche
maßnahmen dann zielgerichtet notwendig
sind die werden werber ergreifen
dann habe ich melanie amann und dann als
allerletzten noch einmal kurz vor
bundeskanzler ich heute noch eine frage
zur impfpflicht stellen der
ursprüngliche zeitplan den sie jetzt so
wenn ich ihre antwort richtig verstanden
habe ein bisschen kassiert haben der
wurde ja von ihnen gesetzt ende februar
anfang märz können wir die impfpflicht
haben haben sie ja im interview gesagt
im zdf jetzt scheint das nicht mehr zu
gelten man hat den eindruck jetzt soll
das thema auf die lange bank geschoben
werden vielleicht gar nicht mehr kommen
auch auf und ihres koalitionspartners
fdp können sie heute noch mal hier sagen
die impfpflicht wird kommen oder wird
sie nicht kommen und wenn ja was ist der
neue zeit raus und
schon dank für ihre frage ich habe die
ganze zeit gesagt dass ich für eine
impfpflicht bin und ich bleibe dabei das
habe ich heute noch mal begründet aber
auch schon bei jedem anderen gelegenheit
wo ich danach gefragt worden bin
ich habe mich von vornherein darauf
festgelegt dass ich finde dass dies ein
prozess sein sollte den der deutsche
bundestag mit einer abgeordneten
entscheidung jenseits des
fraktionszwangs trifft glaube ich ist
der bedeutung dieses themas dass wir
jeden einzelnen mit seinem eigenen
körper berührt auch angemessen aber es
muss schnell gehen und das wird es auch
und davon bin ich sehr überzeugt also
ich setze mich aktiv dafür ein dass es
dazu kommt
der deutsche bundestag tritt jetzt
zusammen und dann gibt es dort die
zuständigen gremien in denen sich die
abgeordneten darüber verständigen wie
sie ihre zeitpläne festlegen und dann
werden wir ja auch hören wie das
geschieht aber alles was ich wahrnehme
ist dass dort auch alle das schnell
voranbringen
als allerletzter moritz müller
vielen dank dass ich eine zweite frage
stellen darf an herrn wüst herr
ministerpräsident sie haben eben noch
mal darauf hingewiesen dass sie so gut
finden dass das eine einigkeit
grundsätzlich gibt in dieser runde jetzt
hat er cdu parteikollege rainer haseloff
ministerpräsident von sachsen anhalt
gerade eben erklärt zweig plus in der
gastro wertes in sachsen anhalt erst mal
nicht geben was bringen denn dann solche
einigkeit appelle und solche runden hier
über stunden lang zusammen sitzen wenn
doch jeder macht war verdankt
glaube wenn sie die genaue begründung
des kollegen haseloffs abwarten dann
werden sie mit dem verweis auf neue
rechtsgrundlagen
sehen die in wenigen tagen durch
bundesrat durch den bundestag ersten
dann durch den bundesrat geschaffen
werden ich glaube darauf bezieht sich
die seine äußerung was die zeitliche
umsetzung angeht so habe ich jedenfalls
auf seinen beitrag im laufe der heutigen
sitzungen verstanden
alle beteiligten dass sie heute am
freitag nahmen mit der frage ausgeharrt
haben wünschen ein gutes wochenende ein
hai in einweg danke mich bei den
kolleginnen kollegen auf dem podium und
beendet die pressekonferenz
so weiter also die pressekonferenz zur
ersten bund länder und des jahres 2022
es geht ja bald schon weiter am 24
januar hat olaf scholz gesagt und auch
franziska giffey betont wird es schon
weitergehen mit der nächsten runde dann
will man sich wieder zusammensetzen und
wieder beraten ob es noch mehr zu tun
gibt in sachen corona bekämpfung
pandemie bekämpfung heute die
entscheidenden schritte auch auf der
basis des expertenrats ja einberufen
worden ist von der neuen bundesregierung
und vom neuen bundeskanzler offenbar
macht sich das positiv bemerkt bei denen
die veranstaltung heute hatten nicht
lange nicht so gedauert wie wir das aus
früheren bund und länder runden kennen
also offenbar war sie und franziska
gefallen hat das ja auch gesagt gut
vorbereitet eben auch muss man
wahrscheinlich sagen durch die
expertenrunde die sehr klar gesagt und
definiert hat was in den nächsten wochen
möglich wird darum die omikron variante
zumindest zu stoppen oder zumindest
diese welle mit dieser omikron variante
nicht so groß werden zu lassen dass
dieses land in schwierigkeiten gerät
entsprechende vorkehrungen sind
getroffen worden es soll zweig plus
geben in restaurants in gaststätten aber
auch in cafés und das bedeutet eben auf
der einen seite dass man entweder
geimpft gewesen dass auf jeden fall sein
muss oder entweder einen negativen test
dabei haben muss einen tagesaktuellen
oder man muss gebucht hat sein dann kann
man die restaurants ohne einen weiteren
test betreten dass es der eine wichtige
punkt der heute hier beschlossen worden
ist und der andere sicherlich der im
zusammenhang mit den quarantäne regeln
die doch deutlich verkürzt werden sollen
die zeiten für quarantäne von
kontaktpersonen von infizierten aber
auch von infizierten selber diese zeiten
sollen in so einen deutlich reduziert
werden oder erkennbar zumindest
hintergrund ist hier dass man sich
sorgen gemacht über die
versorgungseinrichtungen in der
bundesrepublik also krankenhäuser alten
namen pflegeheim auf der einen seite
polizei und feuerwehr die natürlich auch
durch diese schnell grassierende virus
betroffen sein können beispielsweise
aber daneben auch energie und wasser
unternehmen also wie man schützen indem
man hier diese möglichkeiten gibt dass
die beschäftigten aus diesem bereich
schneller an ihren arbeitsplatz
zurückkehren können weil man nicht
ausschließen kann und das ist auch
wiederholt angeklungen in dieser
pressekonferenz dass sich die omikron
variante sehr schnell ausbreitet und
dass auch der krankenstand in der
bundesrepublik ist sehr hoch sein wird
die einzige hoffnung die besteht dass
diese omikron variante nicht
gefährlicher zumindest ist als die jetzt
zu langsam zurückgehende data variante
aber auch dass er noch mal gesagt die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es schwere
erkrankungen gibt auch die omikron die
ist nicht komplett ausgeschlossen auch
wenn es immer wieder heißt dass die
verläufe möglicherweise milder und etwas
ungefährlicher sind die krankenhäuser
wird es wahrscheinlich jedenfalls wenn
die voraussagen stimmen trotzdem sehr
belasten nicht unbedingt auf den
intensivstationen aber allgemein und
auch das hätte sicherlich folgen für das
gesundheitssystem in unserem land
stephan kohler ja wir danken ganz
herzlich in berlin herrscht für diese
lebendige und vollständige
zusammenfassung dessen und schauen jetzt
meine damen und herren mal auf
diejenigen die das ganze umzusetzen
haben in ihren bundesländern das eines
nicht mal diese konferenz und der
bundeskanzler in diesem fall das andere
sind dann die bundesländer mit ihren
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten in diesem reigen die
sind schon eingelaufen teilweise
teilweise laufen sie gerade ein fangen
wir an beim bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten markus söder
heute war ministerpräsident konferenz
allerdings mit wenig 9 insbesondere
wenig neuen für bayern dagegen bleiben
noch viele wissenschaftliche fragen
offen die heute angerissen aber nicht
letztlich geklärt werden können wie ist
der stand omikron wächst auch bei uns
wobei wenn sie die heutigen tag nehmen
bayern auf platz 15 liegt aller
bundesländer wir lagen noch vor einigen
wochen am platz 2 von oben jetzt leben
auf platz 2 von unten das heißt all die
maßnahmen die wir getroffen
im delta management eine große wirkung
wir wissen aber auch dass es kein anlass
sich zurückzulehnen
es ist aber auch kein wettbewerb
zwischen einzelnen bundesländern sondern
wir müssen sehen früher oder später
trifft omikron alle weil es eine hohe
globale als besonders in europa
verbreitungsgeschwindigkeit hat wir
waren am anfang stärker betroffen weil
delta zunächst von österreich gekommen
ist jetzt den norden bei dänemark und
vereinigtes königreich dort eben
stärkere omikron entwicklung haben
bayern bleibt beim team vorsicht aber
auch beim team augenmaß für uns ist
beides sehr wichtig wir müssen neue
erkenntnisse oder wenn es auch
einschränke und gäbe dies auf der basis
wissenschaftlicher erkenntnisse
entscheiden es ist auch wichtig dass man
nicht nur sozusagen virologische
entscheidet sondern auch gesellschaft
mitnimmt und gleichzeitig rechtlich
angemessen entscheidet in der stelle
gibt es fragen sind noch viele fragen zu
omikron offen was erkennbar als auch
nikon offenkundig einen milderen verlauf
hat es konnte von experten heute aber
keine genaue angabe darüber gemacht
werden was bedeutet es auf dauer in der
relation der inzidenz in bisher sind die
bisherigen instanzen die für data
gegelten haben auch automatisch ins
tänzen für omicron und wurde gesagt muss
man wahrscheinlich von anderen
größenordnungen ausgehen man könne es
derzeit aber nicht sagen wenn der
verlauf wieder ist zum zweiten heißt es
aber trotzdem dass mehr fälle betroffen
sind das bedeutet dann dass zwar wenige
intensivbetten dafür normal betten
betroffen sind dafür gab es aber heute
noch keine quantifizierung sondern eine
grundaussage das heißt wir haben noch
eine reihe von fragen zu klären für
bayern in der tat gibt es heute wenig
neues denn die meisten beschlüsse sind
eher unterhalb dem was bayern derzeit
bereits hat zb wir hätten uns gut
vorstellen können die ffb zweimaster
pflicht zur verpflichtung zu machen denn
wir haben diese ffb zwei masten pflicht
bereits beim öpnv beim handel ist wurde
noch mal ausdrücklich von der
wissenschaft gesagt dass das die beste
lösung oder einer der besten lösung sei
weil der sind unserem vorschlag dass für
alle zu machen nicht ganz gefolgt
nochmals im hintergrund max planck
institut hat festgelegt oder ermittelt
dass eine ansteckungsgefahr bei einer
richtig sitzenden fb2 maske sei von 0,1
bei einer schlecht sitzenden von 4 was
heißt sogar bei einer schlecht sitzender
fsb zwar ist es besser als eine normale
medizinische maske die einen schutz von
nur 10 10 ansteckungsgefahr das haben
wir wir sind auch bei der gastronomie
und bei kultur konsequenter als andere
wie sie wissen in anderen bundesländern
sind diskurs offen deswegen haben wir
dann ein ganz erhebliches
ausbruchsgeschehen das kann in beiden
nicht passieren wir haben auch darauf
gedrängt ob man im bereich gastronomie
nicht konsequent ist in dem bereich bars
und kneipen die bei uns zu sind all
diese dinge gibt es woanders nicht dort
sind sie offen auch mit einer gewissen
herausforderung und wir haben 2 gb sport
und kultur zweig plus sogar mit einer
maximalen auslastung deswegen sind wir
skeptisch ob zweige plus in der normalen
castro jenseits von disco jenseits von
bars sinnvoll ist ich habe den
gesundheitsminister gebeten zu prüfen ob
es aus unserer sicht wirklich notwendig
ist wir sind da sehr zurückhaltend und
skeptisch wir haben dazu heute auf einer
kurve koller klären und gemacht wir
waren es am nächsten dienstag dann
abschließend entscheiden positiv ist
dass es neue quarantäne regeln gibt die
der kunde müsste dann uns nochmal
darstellen kann ich glaube dass das
einfacher besser ist impetus gefolgt
waren aber es sind noch viele dinge die
noch offen sind das herstellen der
epidemischen lage ist offen noch offen
ist eine impfpflicht das soll jetzt im
januar eine orientierungs debatte im
deutschen bundestag geben aber auch an
der stelle wissen wir nicht wann und wo
es genau stattfinden kann es fehlt die
darstellung ist pflege bonus wir sind
der festen überzeugung dass pflege bonus
nicht nur in kleinem umfang sondern
großzügig bezahlt werden muss an alle
die im pflegewesen beschäftigt sind auch
in den arztpraxen halten wir das war
ganz ganz wichtig denn dort gibt es
viele medizinische fachangestellte die
gleiche arbeit leisten beispielsweise
beim impfen und ab heute gibt es ja die
wirtschaftshilfe überbrückungshilfe 4
wir halten das nach wie vor für zu wenig
der bund hat einen wirklich großen
notgroschen eigentlich unter corona
tituliert der ist aber für andere themen
die 60 milliarden nachtragshaushalt
gebräuchen eine bessere ausstattung
insbesondere aus den eigenen
kapitalzuschuss und die sogenannte
fixkosten betrifft denn eins muss man
sagen
in dieser pandemie ist der mittelstand
und die selbstständig mit abstand am
stärksten getroffen vielen geht die luft
aus und die bisherigen hilfen werden
nicht ausreichen deswegen setzen wir uns
sehr noch mal dafür ein dass das ganze
erhöht also zusammenfassend gesagt war
das wird ein zwischenbericht
wir werden sehen was die nächsten tage
passiert wir glauben dass wir gar nicht
schlecht gerüstet sind weil wir in fast
allen fällen ein konsequenteres
management haben das data management war
bei uns konsequent als woanders wenn man
eine eigene hotspot regeln das heißt wir
werden jetzt mal abwarten wie sich das
ganze entwickelt und darauf dann
entsprechend reagieren bzw
vorausschauend agieren bei uns sind
deswegen die sicherheitskonzepte mit
testen mit maske und auch mit den neuen
quarantäne regeln glaube ich ein relativ
gutes instrumentarium also
zusammenfassen sagt wir werden weiter ab
wir bleiben dem team vorsicht aber immer
im team augenmaß es ist wichtig
sicherheit aber auch die lebensfähigkeit
der gesellschaft zu gewährleisten wir
können nicht so waren es heute auch aus
schutz haspa quarantäne das ganze land
einstellen werden kritische
infrastruktur die nicht nur die
medizinische die sicherheits auch die
lebensmittelversorgung muss nach wie vor
gewährleistet sein dafür hat man heute
glaube ich schon die notwendigen
weichenstellungen getroffen aber es
bleibt nur eine etappe muss man wirklich
sagen wir treffen unsere
vierundzwanzigster januar wieder
vielleicht auch er das wird man dann
sehen wie die lage sich entwickelt das
was wir jetzt haben können ist ein
produkt geduld vorsicht aber es bleibt
dabei auch unbedingt augenmaß den wir
dafür nicht vergessen dies ist jetzt
mittlerweile in dieser phase der
pandemie nicht nur eine dialogische es
wird zunehmend eine gesellschaftlich
eine soziale herausforderung geworden
und wir müssen multi komplex auf diese
herausforderung reagieren das heißt es
reicht nicht nur den einen standpunkt zu
vertreten das ist die basis für alles
die wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
darüber hinaus braucht es auch das
mitnehmen und wie ich bei der
neujahrsansprache sagte auch heilungs
und versöhnungsprozess des
zusammenwachsens denn wir können diese
vertiefung der gräben in der
gesellschaft nicht auf dauer akzeptieren
der bayerische ministerpräsident
thematisch und inhaltlich gar nicht so
weit entfernt vom bundeskanzler auch
deswegen noch mal zuhört schärfer
unserem korrespondenten in der
hauptstadt man weiß ja doch von diesem
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen bund
länder konferenzen dass man sich da oft
auch sehr verhakt hat diesmal hat man
das offenbar ganz gut vorbereitet wurde
auch von seiten der bundesländer so
bestätigt aber so ganz ohne konflikte
kann es doch wohl nicht abgelaufen sein
oder
nein ganz unter uns ganz ohne
unterschiedliche auffassungen hat
natürlich auch diese runde in der tat
nicht fest finde ich stattgefunden und
wir haben es ja eben auch hören können
bei den äußerungen von markus söder der
sich ja beispielsweise geäußert hat sein
zimmer ffp zwei masken da hat er gesagt
er hätte er sich eine bundesweite masten
pflicht vorstellen können jetzt wird
weiterhin dringlich empfohlen zwei
masken zu tragen einerseits im
einzelhandel beispielsweise aber auch im
öffentlichen nah und fernverkehr also da
hätten sich manche länder sicherlich
weitergehende maßnahmen oder
entscheidungen vorstellen können und es
hat im vorfeld auch einen vorstoß
gegeben von den unionsregierten ländern
plus baden württemberg mit den grünen
ministerpräsidenten kretschmann dass man
gesagt hat der bundesregierung solle
darauf drängen dass die epidemische lage
nationaler tragweite wieder eingeführt
wird die war ja gerade erst im dezember
vom bundestag und dann auch vom
bundesrat verabschiedet worden auf der
basis werden von neuen beschüssen der
ampelkoalition das war im vorfeld an
diese runde herangetragen worden aber da
hat es keinen konsens gegeben und da
jetzt hat man auch in den äußerungen
etwa von hendrik wüst durchaus gehört da
sind einige durchaus noch
unterschiedlicher auffassung dass die
weiteren schritte angeht ja da war die
antwort des bundeskanzlers auch äußerst
knapp und eigentlich so ein typischer
scholz oder
ja das war ja auffällig in den
vergangenen oder bei dieser
pressekonferenz dass die antworten von
olaf scholz auch deutlich kürzer gewesen
sind als bei seiner amtsvorgängerin
angela merkel auch bei diesem thema die
da eben doch eher dazu geneigt hat ein
klein wenig mehr zu erklären und
entsprechend waren die reaktionen
und knappe von olaf scholz auch beim
thema impfpflicht da hat es auch im
vorfeld eine forderung gegeben science
der unionsregierten länder auch wieder
mit den grünen kretschmann aus
baden-württemberg die bundesregierung
solle doch erst zu einerseits einen
gesetzentwurf vorlegen auf der anderen
seite aber auch einen fahrplan bis wann
es denn zu dieser impfpflicht kommen
solle und den diesen vorstoß der
politisch natürlich legitim ist durch
die unionsgeführten bundesländer wobei
aber die frage ist ob er auch politisch
klug ist wenn im grunde geht es ja läuft
es ja darauf hinaus dass eine
entscheidung im bundestag
gefällt und getroffen werden soll also
eine vertretung der gesamten
bundesbürger zumindest so aller derer
die gewählt haben also dass das ganze
dann auf eine möglichst breite basis
gestellt wird was denn dann auch kommen
soll und da hat sich olaf scholz haben
sich aber auch die spd-regierten länder
eindeutig gegen verhalten so zu
verhalten dass ihnen eben dieses papier
eine solche formulierung aufgenommen
werden soll die im fahrplan vorsieht den
fahrplan kennen wir inzwischen aber
trotzdem es wird diese schon mehrfach
zitierte orientierungs debatte geben im
bundestag ende dieses monats und dann
wird wird es eine ganze reihe von
anhörungen geben es müssen ja auch erst
mal noch eine ganze reihe von anträgen
überhaupt erst mal geschrieben und
verfasst werden nämlich beispielsweise
der antrag für eine solche impfpflicht
aber auch möglicherweise ein
alternativvorschlag
der eine abgestufte variante vorsieht
also der möglicherweise eine impfpflicht
nur für besonders gefährdete gruppen
vorsieht die gibt es aber noch gar nicht
aber das wird dann möglicherweise bis
anfang februar mit der februar durchaus
der fall sein können die werden dann
beraten werden dann wird es die
anhörungen im bundestag geben und dann
richtung ende des quartals dann
mutmaßlich auch eine abstimmung über
diese drei wenn es denn drei werden
gruppenanträge die fraktionsbildung ist
ja aufgehoben bei diesem thema das heißt
ihr gewissen die abgeordneten können wir
ganz frei nach ihrem gewissen
entscheiden und sich verhalten und
entsprechend abstimmen ja das haben wir
schon vorher gehört dass andere die die
frage die vielleicht nicht ganz kurz am
ende übrig bleibt es ist ja auch eine
koalition von drei parteien und man hat
ja schon im vorfeld mitbekommen dass man
sich da nicht so ganz klar ist in der
meinungsbildung war er den verschiedenen
parteien was die impfpflicht betrifft
ist da noch sprengkraft oder ist das
jetzt auch nicht
das ist ja mit dem heutigen tag nicht
weg denn das ist ja eine ganz andere
ebene die hier heute beraten hat heute
waren ja die länder mit der
bundesregierung zusammen ob die
koalition zu einem gemeinsamen zu einer
gemeinsamen haltung kommt da bin ich mir
gar nicht so sicher das ist auch gar
nicht möglich nachdem was ich eben
gesagt habe zum thema fraktions bindung
bei dieser abstimmung das ist schon zu
beginn dieser diskussion überhaupt
nämlich mit dem dezember gesagt worden
dass die abgeordneten völlig frei
entscheiden können und das gilt
natürlich auch für die ampelkoalition
und da wissen wir dass es da sehr
strenge verfechter gibt bundeskanzler
zum beispiel aber auch viele grüne die
sehr für eine solche pflicht sind es
gibt auch viele unions-abgeordnete
übrigens sie für eine impfpflicht sind
aber wenn wir ausschließlich auf die
koalition und auf die ampel gucken gibt
es da natürlich gibt es auch eine ganze
reihe von fdp-abgeordneten die sich
vehement gegen eine impfpflicht
einsetzen und sagen das was aber auch
heute wie gesagt worden ist die
impfkampagne muss verstärkt werden wir
müssen mehr das müssen mehr leute
irgendwie dazu gebracht werden dass sie
sich impfen lassen also dieses dieser
punkt ist eben auch da aber das ist
schlussendlich zu einer sprengkraft
führt für die sind noch recht neue
ampelkoalition das denke ich eigentlich
nicht
unsere korrespondentin der hauptstadt
dankeschön für die einschätzungen
zusammenfassungen sind wir noch besser
im bild jetzt und wir schauen noch
weiter in die länder danke er hat und
wir gehen jetzt nach sachsen anhalts
ministerpräsident reiner haseloff nach
den bund-länder-verhandlungen
der im status die
situation wird wesentlichen auch darüber
entscheiden wie wir die nächste welle
die kommen könnte auch mit der neuen
mutante bewältigen und die
zahlen sind so dass wir zwar eine
positive bewegung sehen aber auch
bezüglich der immer noch ungeimpften
nicht zufrieden sein können weil das
einfach eine zu große zahl ist die
auch mehrheitlich das ist heute auch
noch mal von professor krömer bestätigt
worden sascha riether ja auch schafft
dieser expertenkommission der
bundesregierung ist dass die probleme
dadurch entstehen dass zu viele
ungeimpfte deutschlandweit da sind und
bei uns sind das in der altersgruppe 12
bis 17 wenn man noch
49.000 wobei ich da optimistisch bin
dass wenn das schulsystem jetzt wieder
in gang kommt dann automatisch auch
nehmen den test auch parallel die
aktivitäten vor ort in den schulen und
im umfeld der schulen realisiert werden
kann aber zwischen 18 und 59 haben wir
immer noch
326.000 ungeimpfte und in der
altersgruppe über 60 und not 23.000 über
60 123000 das ist auch eigentlich das
problem wenn wir uns die altersstruktur
der
intensivbetten belege und berlinerinnen
ansehen dann dann finden wir hier ja
natürlich auch aus den letzten monaten
heraus die meisten patientinnen und
patienten das heißt wir haben immer noch
ungeimpft
gegenüber dem was im bau wäre
656.000 im lande das ist also unsere
große aufgabe und deswegen zog sich das
heute auch durch das wie gesagt die
impfkampagne nicht nachgelassen werden
darf in verbindung jetzt auch mit der
booster kampagne und das auch der
bundesgesundheitsminister und der
kanzler gerade nochmal bestätigt haben
bezüglich der ressourcen die da sind das
ausreichend impfstoff da ist
gleichwertig
mehrheitlich bzw vorrangig der biontech
impfstoff für die bis 30 jährigen
eingesetzt werden soll und alles andere
dann auch zur musterung mit moderner
erfolgen kann es ist ausreichend
impfstoff da und die strukturen stehen
die arbeitsfähigkeit ist da sie sind in
teilen
durchaus noch weiter auslastungs fähig
und bereit wie man die landrätin
landräte
bestätigen und deswegen ist es an dieser
stelle nochmal hervorzuheben dass
wir diese kapazitäten auch nutzen müssen
wir haben wie gesagt heute
uns auf das grundsätzliche weitere
vorgehen verständigt auf der basis auch
das aktuellen ist standes der uns vom
schaft jahr expertenkommission krömer
dort vorgetragen wurde es lässt sich für
deutschland insgesamt so benennen dass
die infektionszahlen wieder nach oben
gehen aber sich das härtet sich von tag
zu tag die entsprechenden
krankheitsbilder
anders darstellen als bei delta oder
davor dass
höhere infektiosität aber milde verläufe
so dass man also ich also bezüglich der
instrumente sehr
anpassungsfähig oder aktionsfähig wie
mehrheitlich heute immer wieder gesagt
wird auch durch die spezialisten
verhalten muss im politischen geschäft
das heißt es kann dass wir sehen sich
auf einige zahlen wir sind momentan mit
der vierte niedrigsten incidents
unterwegs in deutschland und fast
ausschließlich delta ich sage auch
gleich noch mal was das für uns auf
einer fachlichen seite ja bedeutet
dass wir aber eben auch länder haben die
zum beispiel an dänemark an grenzen oder
im flughafen haben wie frankfurt hessen
wo in 50 prozent + mehr inzwischen
nikon varianten darstellen bei der
sequenzierung und demzufolge
ist da mehr oder werden ja auch die
quantitative nutzung auch der
intensivbetten kapazitäten und so weiter
und so fort entsprechend auf einer
anderen entwicklungslinie als wir das
von delta oder den willen davor und den
mutanten mutationen davor entsprechend
kennen und deswegen haben wir uns darauf
verständigt dass wir bezüglich das dass
der zeitliche taktung der heute nochmal
formulierten maßnahmen
auf keine kein festes datum beziehen
sondern auch nicht nur wegen der
laufzeiten die unterschiedlich sind in
den ländern was verordnung anbelangt
auch die individualitäten entsprechend
wiederfinden
in der herangehensweise der bewältigung
der pandemie damit meinen wir dass wir
letztendlich auch entscheiden müssen
welches instrument wann gezogen wird und
an welcher stelle man auch im sinne der
transparenz und nachvollziehbarkeit für
die bürgerinnen und bürger
welche maßnahme dann auch schalten fakt
dass einst das tableau ist einheitlich
und wie gesagt aufgrund der großen
unterschiedlichkeiten muss hier
unterschiedlich agiert werden und das
führt dazu dass wir die nächste runde
auch der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
erst am 24 haben weil wir bezüglich auch
der neuen mutante die ja nun einigen
bundesländern dominant ist entsprechend
zu wenig datenbasis haben und dort noch
sehr zielgerichtet auch noch mal
ansetzen zu können da hilft es nicht mit
den normalen abstrakten oder bisher
pauschal überall zur gleichen zeit
angewendeten maßnahmen etwas zu machen
sondern da muss ja spezifischer agiert
werden und deswegen ist es auch gut dass
man sozusagen über die landesverordnung
diese unterschiedlichkeit abbilden kann
vierundzwanzigster
nochmal für uns vom tableau her bis zum
18 läuft unsere jetzt hier verordnung
dann müssen wir während der
entsprechenden laufzeit
schauen inwieweit wir bis zum 24 nochmal
eine verlängerung brücke ziehen oder das
könnte rein theoretisch jeden tag aber
gehen wir mal jetzt in etwas grösseren
zyklen ist es ja auch sinnvoller weise
angeboten hat über die weihnachtstage
wo sie das geschehen auch selber erleben
konnten dass es sich doch deutlich
beruhigt hat bei uns dass die deutlich
reduzierter kontakt dichter dass wir
jetzt schauen müssen wenn die kontakten
jetzt wieder hoch gehen das schulsystem
und das wiederanspringen der wirtschaft
dass wir das im blick behalten und
jederzeit reagieren können und inwieweit
wir dann vom 19 bis 24 925 nochmal
lückenschluss machen müssen oder dann
den die dann ja wieder neu
formatierte beschlusslage zugrunde legen
für weitere maßnahmenpakete das muss man
dann natürlich als sehr flexibel
entscheiden
wir haben uns darauf verständigt auch in
der regierungsspitze
zuständige ministerin aber auch meine
beiden stellvertretern dass wir
aufgrund dessen dass wir fast komplett
noch im alten system unterwegs sind bei
uns ist delta
fast zu 99 100 prozent die entsprechende
krankheitsursache dass wir deswegen das
was zb in
bremen oder und schleswig-holstein
notwendig ist die andere mutante andere
maßnahmen erforderlich macht bei uns
derzeit nicht greifen oder ganz im
gegenteil wir haben sogar einen
bestimmten stellen zum beispiel was die
kombination boostern und testen
anbelangt schärfere maßnahmen als alle
anderen länder das hat sich als richtig
erwiesen weil das für die hat dort
greifen und härter wirkende delta
mutation entsprechend auch gut
ausgezahlt hat wenn wir faktisch an
dieser stelle lockerungen gemacht hätten
wie andere bundesländer
dann wäre das sozusagen für die
bewältigung der data variante die
ausschließlich bis auf ganz wenige fälle
50 personen in der 3
dort eine rolle gespielt hätten wir das
falsche instrumentarium und auch die
falschen maßnahmenbündel zur verfügung
gehabt das heißt da durch das zelt bei
uns die mutante ist müssen wir sozusagen
das was wir bisher auf einen schärferen
maßnahmen haben bis hin dass wir die
ganze zeit auch bars und kneipen und
alles schön zu hatten die liefen
übrigens im norden noch
das ist alles ja bei uns raus und bleibt
auch draußen und da muss auch nichts
verschafft werden sondern wir bleiben
bei diesen früher als schärfer aber
inzwischen als jetzt doch insgesamt
normal auch von den anderen kolleginnen
und kollegen einen geschätzten maßnahmen
reiner haseloff aus magdeburg und wir
gehen von magdeburg nach wiesbaden die
landeshauptstadt von hessen doch dass
ministerpräsident volker bouffier
wir haben wie wir das alte ja beendet
haben das neue auch wieder gestartet mit
einer ministerin sind konferenz
gemeinsam mit dem bundeskanzler in der
bundesregierung wir hatten uns
verabredet vor weihnachten dass wir
zeitnah uns mit der situation befassen
insbesondere auch in den blick nehmen
wie sich die neue variante omikron im
lande entwickelt was daraus
gegebenenfalls anschlüssen zu ziehen ist
und wie wir damit umgehen
ich darf mal vorneweg sagen das was uns
hier in hessen betrifft werde ich gleich
noch mal näher erläutern zunächst ist
mir wichtig darauf hinzuweisen dass wir
heute noch einmal einen sehr aktuellen
berichte sogenannten experten kommission
bekommen haben und dabei vielleicht drei
dinge besonders hervorstechen die
experten haben uns vermittelt dass die
bisherigen maßnahmen gewirkt haben im
vergleich zu vielen anderen ländern um
uns herum ist der anstieg dieser
infektionen in deutschland wesentlich
langsamer voran gegangen und das war ja
immer unser großes ziel das wir
versuchen diese infektionen die man
nicht verhindern kann aber wenigstens in
der ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit
entsprechend einzudämmen und wir haben
jetzt eine verdopplung sozusagen von 5,5
tagen im vergleich zu anderen ländern
los ist in zwei oder drei tagen alles
verdoppelt ist das durchaus erfolgreich
und wenn die maßnahmen die wir bisher
gemacht haben gegriffen haben spricht ja
gerade alles dafür dass man diese
maßnahmen fortsetzung das bedeutet jetzt
für hessen
wir haben eine verordnung die vieles
auch von dem was wir heute beschlossen
haben bereits vorweggenommen hat dass
wir die bisherigen regeln in hessen
beibehalten es gibt keine guten gründe
dort veränderungen im hinblick auf
lockerungen oder ähnliches vorzunehmen
warum wir haben heute auch wieder sehr
intensiv über die frage diskutiert wie
belastbar sind eigentlich die
erkenntnisse die bislang gewonnen wurden
und einiges gibt es aber es ist nicht so
belastbar dass man darauf sozusagen
jetzt neue regeln gründen könnte ich
will darauf hinweisen und das zeigen
auch die zahlen in hessen wir haben eine
hohe ansteckung aber glücklicherweise
ist diese hohe ansteckung bisher
insbesondere in unseren
intensivstationen nicht deutlich
geworden die belastung dort ist hoch
nach wie vor aber sie hat sich nicht
entsprechend
weiterentwickelt sowie das zunächst
einmal zu befürchten weil sie werden
sich vielleicht erinnern viele experten
haben vorhergesagt dass an weihnachten
und neujahr
eine absolute belasse überlastung bei
den intensivstationen stattfinden würde
das ist glücklicherweise nicht
eingetreten damit das auch niemand
missversteht die belastung dort ist
immer noch extrem hoch und es geht ja
nicht nur um die intensivstation es geht
ja auch die allgemeine belastung in den
krankenhäusern aber wir dürfen durchaus
mit freude zur kenntnis nehmen dass
diese vorhergesagte explosionen und
dramatik die wir dann zu erwarten ja
bitten gott sei dank nicht eingetreten
ist gleichwohl
es bleibt dabei wir haben davon
auszugehen dass sich weiter die
infektionszahlen erhöhen das erleben wir
ja auch bei uns in hessen zurzeit wir
sind knapp unter dem bundesdurchschnitt
was die inzidenz 'nen angeht bei der
hospitalisierung rate sind viele
bisschen unter dem bundesdurchschnitt
sie sogar leicht zurückgegangen
also im ergebnis die bisherigen
maßnahmen haben sich bewährt und die
werden wir in hessen fortsetzen
zum zweiten haben wir uns heute auch
beschäftigt mit dem stichwort kritische
infrastruktur dabei geht es um folgendes
was man vielleicht so erklären kann wenn
sehr viele menschen sich infizieren dann
müssen sie nach den regeln die bisher
gelten alle in quarantäne
wenn ganz viele in quarantäne gehen
müssen dann kann es durchaus sein dass
in wichtigen bereichen nicht genügend
personen mehr vorhanden sind um die
entsprechenden aufgaben zu erfüllen sie
kennen die beispiele von feuerwehr und
polizei aber eben viele andere bereiche
auch denken sie an die logistik denken
sie an die lastwagen fahrerinnen und
fahrer das alles gehört dazu wir haben
hier in hessen zwischen weihnachten und
neujahr mit allen landesbehörden und den
kommunen entsprechende pläne aufgestellt
wir glauben dass wir dort sehr gut
vorbereitet sind und insofern ist das
was auch heute von den bund an die
länder adressiert wurde in hessen schon
erfolgt das sind wir glaube ich auf
gutem wege dazu gehört dann und das war
heute einer der wesentlichen
entscheidungen dass wir der auffassung
sind dass die bisherigen quarantäne
regeln geändert werden sollen diese
änderungen sind durchaus von belang und
ich will ohne sie zu verwirren einfach
mal auf ein paar punkte eingehen sie
wissen bisher gibt es keine
ausnahmeregelungen quarantäne und dann
kann man sich frei testen wenn das
möglich ist und das wird jetzt geändert
zunächst einmal bin ich darauf hinweisen
dass wir bei den kontaktpersonen
beschlossen haben das für diejenigen die
bereits gebucht sind die also die dritte
impfung bekommen haben keine quarantäne
in zukunft mehr erforderlich ist das ist
eine wesentliche veränderung
und ist aus meiner sicht auch eine sehr
sehr gute begründung sich impfen zu
lassen also das zieht sich ja durch jede
konferenz und es gehört auch heute hier
dazu der beste schutz ist immer das
impfen wir sind gut vorangekommen aber
wir sind noch lange nicht da wo wir
eigentlich hinwollen und an dem beispiel
kann man etwas zeigen wusstet ist und
hat entsprechend als kontaktpersonen
dann kontakt gehabt wird jemand der
infiziert ist der braucht in zukunft
nicht mehr in quarantäne
diejenigen die eine entsprechende
infektion haben oder auch die die einer
entsprechenden kontakt hatten aber noch
nicht gebucht sind also wenn sie wollen
alle anderen für die gelten in zukunft
die situation dass nach sieben tagen man
mit einem zertifizierten an die gentest
oder einen pcr-test sich frei testen
lassen kann das ist eine kürzere frist
als das bisher der fall war eine
besondere regelung soll gelten für
diejenigen die im bereich der
krankenhäuser pflegeeinrichtungen tätig
sind weil dort wo normale menschen sind
die besonderen schutz frauen dort geht
es auch nach sieben tagen allerdings auf
jeden fall pcr test und auch 48 stunden
symptomfrei auch das ist neu
zahn unter dem bundesschnitt bei der
inzidenz ganz anders sieht es in
thüringen aus seit langer zeit ist
thüringen absolute spitzenreiter in den
infektionszahlen leider deswegen jetzt
auch der besonders besondere augenmerk
auf die bemerkungen von bodo ramelow den
ministerpräsidenten in erfurt
die bundesrepublik deutschland bereitet
sich auf die herausforderungen durch die
neue variante ohne komfort und es war
notwendig dass wir uns jetzt heute sehr
ausführlich darüber verständigt haben
einerseits was uns der ex dass die
expertengremien das expertengremium das
jetzt neu von der bundesregierung
berufen worden ist
und vielleicht auch die
voraussetzungen die gegeben worden sind
durch den neuen bundeseinheitlichen
krisenstab mit dem wir uns ja jetzt
gerade in erfurt getroffen haben mit dem
generalmajor bayern der sich auch von
den voraussetzungen wie wir in thüringen
arbeiten hat überzeugen können und
einiges von unseren erfahrungen
mitgenommen hat in die zusammenhängenden
abstimmung und das kooperieren
miteinander
alles das hat heute auch eine rolle
gespielt aber in jedem fall haben wir
festgestellt dass wir bislang in der
bundesrepublik ist immer noch geschafft
haben dass wir noch nicht so hart in das
infektionsgeschehen eingetreten sind wie
es zum beispiel in unseren nachbarn
bunten unseren nachbarländern schon
stattfindet italien oder österreich
frankreich niederlande haben wir jetzt
ja schon ein anstieg england einen
signifikanten anstieg und das was wir
gerade feststellen ist auch in thüringen
dass die ersten frühen signale wir haben
ja das neue frühwarnsystem
das jetzt auch schon funktioniert und
läuft in dem mit dem abwasser messungen
und in diesen abwasser messung in zwei
abmessungen punkten konnten wir
mittlerweile
positive befunde zu und konnten
feststellen dass heißt es wird diese
infektionsgeschehen wird auf uns
zukommen darauf haben wir uns
vorbereitet das was an maßnahmen
beschlossen worden ist ich darf in
erinnerung rufen dass thüringen ein
bundesland ist dass in den letzten
monaten immer auf der höchsten
infektionswelle gelegen hat und diese
höchste infektionsrate hat ja bei uns
dazu geführt dass wir die ganze zeit
über schon sehr strikte restriktionen
haben das heißt das was wir heute
bundesweit festgelegt haben sind die
dinge die in thüringen für die hotspot
regionen jetzt schon gültigkeit hatten
das heißt unsere jetzige verordnungs
regelung muss nicht angepasst werden wir
haben lediglich bei dem abstandsgebot in
der gastronomie zweig plus haben wir
beten dass es kein datum dorthin
angenommen wird sondern es für jedes
bundesland im anschluss von dieser
verordnung in die nächste auch die 2g
plus regelung aufgenommen werden muss
das werden wir auch veranlassen das sind
aber die regeln die bei uns in den hot
spot regionen
incidents abhängig ja schon gegolten
haben also da wo die tausender incidents
überschritten war waren diese regelung
schon in den vorschriften mit vorgesehen
das heißt wir werden sie jetzt allgemein
erfassen und ich darf ankündigen dass
wir die diese beschlüsse von heute 1
arbeiten in die beschlussvorlage zum 23
januar darüber haben wir aber am
dienstag schon im kabinett sehr
ausführlich geredet das heißt die
voraussetzungen die wir jetzt die an
schussgenauigkeit
vornehmen ist eingeleitet auch das
verfahren parlaments
beteiligungsverfahren ist eingeleitet
die beschlüsse von heute werden jetzt
auch zügig dem parlament zugeleitet
positive punkt für heute ist dass die
wirtschaftshilfen um die wir gebeten
hatten als wir ja in thüringen schon
härte in den in die
abstandsregelungen rein mussten als die
weihnachts werke geschlossen werden
mussten dass diese wirtschaftshilfen ab
heute freigeschaltet sind ich finde das
ist gut und wichtig zu wissen dass die
wirtschaft hilfen 4 ab heute auf den
möglichen kanälen die hinlänglich auch
den wirtschaftsvertretern und
bratsche unbekannt sind das die ab heute
freigeschaltet sind und dass wir jetzt
alles getan und vorbereitet haben was an
risikovorsorge bei einem anstieg von
infektionen wie ich jetzt gerade in
niedersachsen und bremen beobachtet
werden kann das muss man einfach
erwähnen wir waren die ganze zeit das
bundesland das auf platz eins gelegen
hat mittlerweile hat uns bremen die mit
einer viel höheren
impfquote gesegnet waren bremen hat uns
jetzt die rote laterne abgenommen das
ist ein alarmierender hinweis darauf
dass die frage wie wird das sich
auswirken in den krankenhäusern was
brauchen wir ein medizinischer vorsorge
um den menschen beizustehen
die dann mit der neuen infektionsrate
oder dem der neuen infektions variante
und der deutlich höheren infektionsrate
auch in den krankenhäusern ankommen dass
wir auch dort vorbereitet sind
bislang ist es so dass thüringen immer
noch von der solidarität der anderen
bundesländern gezehrt hat jetzt müssen
wir uns vorbereiten dass wir auch
wiederum unsere patienten zügig selber
versorgen können müssen darüber haben
wir auch mit general mallorca geredet
damit wir noch
unterstützungskräfte bekommen von der
bundeswehr und zwar fachkräfte da gibt
es einigen bedarf jetzt der angefordert
ist auch das wird jetzt eingeleitet und
von daher gehe ich davon aus dass wir
mit den herausforderungen die jetzt in
uns gestellt sind so
ausgerichtet sind dass wir in der lage
sind jetzt die notwendigen beschluss
umsetzungen die deutschlandweit in kraft
treten auch in thüringen sehr zeitnah in
wirkung setzen aus meiner perspektive
kann man jetzt sagen dass es umso
wichtiger ist dass die menschen für sich
entscheiden dass sie die chance des
impfen nutzen denn ich will nochmals
sehr deutlich darauf hinweisen dass die
bude in
thüringen von anfang an so geregelt
worden ist wir waren das bundesland das
zuerst schon auf die fünf monats
regelung umgeschaltet hat und wir haben
vor weihnachten die
impftermine frei geschaltet dass man
sich bustan kann drei monate nach der
zweiten impfung das heißt meine bitte an
die bürgerinnen und bürger ist machen
sie gebrauch davon machen sie jetzt auch
gebrauch davon dass sie sich terminlich
einordnen wann sie sich ihre impfungen
abholen und achten sie darauf dass auch
die booster impfung jetzt möglichst
zeitnah erfolgt das ist der höchste
schutz den man sich gegen diese omikron
variante an infektionsgeschehen im
moment auch gewähren kann und an alle
menschen die skeptisch sind den sei
nochmal deutlich gesagt wer auf den tod
impfstoff gewartet hat der wird jetzt
bis ende januar ein erstes umfassendes
angebot bekommen und auch da meine bitte
kümmern sie sich um die termine denn
sobald das ihm der impfstoff da ist auch
die dritte variante des impfstoffs da
heißt steht ihnen das ganze im portal
und die im teams zur verfügung
omikron hat also auch schon thüringen
erreicht auch wenn die zahlen dort noch
nicht so hoch sind wie beispielsweise in
den nordländern von deutschland denn von
den nachbarländern kommen die
infektionen mit omikron doch massiv
eingetragen darunter leidet auch
mecklenburg vorpommern dort war man ja
auch mal besonders strikt mit den
maßnahmen jetzt dazu mecklenburg
vorpommern mecklenburg vorpommerns
ministerpräsidentin manuela schwesig
wir hatten heute mit bundeskanzler
scheut die gemeinsame konferenz der
ministerpräsidenten und minister
und es ging vor allem darum wie wir uns
auf die omikron variante in deutschland
besser vorbereiten und vor allem was es
an konkreten sachen zu tun gibt und um
es vorweg zu nehmen wir haben heute in
der mpk beschlossen vor allem die regeln
die in mecklenburg vorpommern schon seit
einigen wochen gelten jetzt auch in ganz
deutschland einzuführen dazu gehört vor
allem die schließung von clubs und
diskotheken in allen bundesländern und
auch zweig plus zum beispiel in der
gastronomie
und deshalb wird sich auch für unser
bundesland nicht so viel ändern denn wir
haben schon viele der regeln über die
heute diskutiert wurde und york
beschlossen worden sind in unserem land
umgesetzt und das zeigt ja dass eben
auch der weg von mecklenburg vorpommern
der richtige ist wir haben vor allem
eine gemeinsame einschätzung des
expertenrates bekommen die gemeinsame
einschätzung ist dass die vor
weihnachten beschlossenen maßnahmen zur
reduzierung der kontakte und die große
zahl der booster impfung im laufe des
dezembers dazu beigetragen haben dass
sich die omikron variante nicht so
schnell ausbreitet dass es aber keine
entwarnung gibt sondern dass wir damit
rechnen müssen dass in den nächsten
tagen die zahl der omicron fälle
erheblich ansteigt und
das sehen wir mit großen sorgen vor
allem deshalb weil wir bereits eine
große belastung in den krankenhäusern
haben nochmal zur erinnerung in unserem
land sind die betten die wir für koma
patienten auf der intensivstation
freigehalten haben bereits zu 91 prozent
belegt und wenn jetzt noch viele im econ
fälle dazukommen wird das sehr schwer
und deswegen sehen wir auch die nächsten
wochen sehr kritisch und haben uns
darauf auch mit einem krisenstab
vorbereitet vor diesem hintergrund sind
wir wo uns eigentlich zwischen bund und
ländern dass es bei den bestehenden
kontakt beschränkungen bleiben muss und
deshalb will ich sie auch noch einmal
wiederholen bei treffen an ungeimpfte
personen teilnehmen gilt die regel
maximal der haushalt plus zwei weitere
person aus einem anderen haushalt also
wenn ich zum beispiel ungeimpften dann
kann ich mit meiner familie zusammen
kommen und maximal noch mit zwei
weiteren personen zum beispiel den
eltern aus einem anderen haushalt bei
treffen an denen ausschließlich geimpfte
und genese teilnehmen lautet die formel
maximal zehn personen immer dazu gehören
kinder bis 14 jahre ein zweiter punkt
wir raten dringend dazu jetzt stärker
auf b2 masken zu setzen wir alle haben
uns an die masten in der kroner pandemie
gewöhnt und es ist wieder wichtig
stärker auf ft2 zu setzen so wie schon
im letzten winter und vor allem dort wo
es eng ist wo wir in innenräumen sind zb
pnv und beim einkaufen und der dritte
punkt die das eben eine reihe von
schutzmaßnahmen beschlossen worden sind
die auch schon in mv gelten die 2g plus
regel in der gastronomie und auch die
clubs und diskotheken es gibt für mich
und vorpommern eine kleine erleichterung
auch bei uns gilt das wenn die 2g plus
in dem restaurant haben das gewusst
hätte davon ausgenommen sind allerdings
erst nach 14 tagen das soll jetzt
zukünftig sofort mit der booster impfung
gelten das ist eine erleichterung für
alle die sich boostern lassen und
insbesondere natürlich auch für die
gastronomie und
das setzen wir natürlich dann auch eine
pause um eine große diskussion war in
den letzten tagen eine neue quarantäne
regel die gemeinsame einschätzung war
heute dass wir einerseits die quarantäne
regeln ein bisschen lockern können aber
auf der anderen seite sind natürlich
auch beibehalten müssen und deshalb wird
es zukünftig quarantäne regeln geben die
erleichterungen bringen bisher gilt für
kontaktpersonen einer mit der nikon
virusvariante infizierten personen die
strikte quarantäne von 14 tagen die
nicht durch einen negativen test
vorzeitig beendet werden
künftig sollen diejenigen
kontaktpersonen die einen vollständigen
impfschutz durch die
auffrischungsimpfung also musterung
kamen von der quarantäne ausgenommen
werden und das gilt natürlich auch für
vergleichbare gruppen zum beispiel
genesen und für alle übrigen enden die
endet die isolation die quarantäne in
der regel nach zehn tagen und das ist
jetzt sehr wichtig denn
das ist ein riesen vorteil wenn man
gewusst hat ist wir müssen alle davon
aus gehen dass wir sehr sehr hohe
infektionszahlen bekommen durch omikron
und dass wir potenziell dadurch alle
kontaktpersonen von einem infizierten
werden wenn es sehr viele infizierte
gibt und dann ist es wenn man gewusst
hat ist vielleicht der weil man nicht in
quarantäne gehen muss das bedeutet ich
kann zur arbeit gehen das bedeutet ich
kann sag ich mal nicht weiter frei
bewegen und quarantäne ist schon eine
große einschränkung und deswegen rate
ich auch deshalb allen zur besserung
weil man dann nicht in quarantäne muss
wenn man kontaktperson ist
künftig wird es möglich sein nach einer
nachgewiesenen infektion oder als
kontaktpersonen sich bereits nach sieben
tagen durch einen pcr oder
zertifizierten antigen schnelltest drei
zu testen damit werden wir auch den
herausforderungen für die kritische
infrastruktur rechnung tragen für
schülerinnen und schüler sowie kinder in
der kinderbetreuung gibt es eine weitere
erleichterung da kann bereits die
quarantäne nach fünf tagen durch einen
pcr oder antigen schnelltest beendet
werden darin den schulen und kitas
regelmäßig getestet wird
wichtig ist diesmal zu betonen
bundesweit gelten die gleichen regeln
auch in mainz in rheinland pfalz
ministerpräsident im halo 3 erstellt die
maßnahmen vor
wir haben uns verabredungsgemäß heute
wieder getroffen in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit dem
bundeskanzler und im kabinett und wir
haben uns ja vorgenommen im letzten jahr
schon dass wir uns ständig miteinander
treffen und absprechen und abstimmen das
der wissenschaft oder expertenrat vorher
tags und wir mit den ergebnissen dann
entsprechend auch umgehen können als
zuständige regierungschefs und chefin
und ich kann heute sagen der ist der
expertenrat der bundesregierung ist aus
meiner sicht gold wert weil wir einfach
profitieren von unglaublich viel
expertise die auch interdisziplinär
zusammengesetzt ist und so haben wir
heute vor allem die lage besprochen mit
blick auf die omikron variante und
welche schlüsse werde am heutigen tag
daraus gezogen habe darüber ziehen
wollen wir haben zunächst festgestellt
dass die schutzmaßnahmen zum dezember
die wir beschlossen haben wirklich auch
geholfen haben in rheinland-pfalz sag
ich sagen jetzt der 2 gibt es regelungen
haben wir sehr frühzeitig eigentlich
auch schon ziemlich strenge maßnahmen
ergriffen und wir kommen auch mit den
booster impfungen wirklich sehr gut
voran da will ich mich auch wirklich
sehr sehr herzlich bedanken bei unseren
bürgern bürgerinnen die auch sehr
verantwortungsvoll über die feiertage
agiert haben das ergebnis ist auch dass
unsere zahlen wirklich erst mal relativ
niedrig geblieben sind wir sind
bundesweit eigentlich mit einer der
niedrigsten in tänzen allerdings muss
man sagen dass dieser vorsprung den wir
uns auch ganz stück gearbeitet haben
denn jetzt wirklich auch ganz ganz
schnell
dahinschmelzen wird weil omikron nach
den neuesten berechnungen und
schätzungen von bio sensi am heutigen
tag bereits zu 80 prozent in rheinland
pfalz auch verbreitet ist und das
bedeutet dass wir ein einfaches
miterleben werden dass unsere in tänzen
wirke sehr stark steigen werden wenn man
vielleicht so eine zahlt sich merkt im
vergleich zum letzten freitag haben sich
jetzt die zahlen charakter verdoppelt
und das wird auch die entwicklung seien
mit der wir jetzt in der nächsten zeit
konfrontiert werden trotzdem will ich
noch mal sagen dass boost angeht und
schreite es sehr schnell voran um ihn
vielleicht mal eine vergleichszahl zu
sagen heute genau ist der 600.000
beantragt in unserem landesportal
bearbeitet worden seit dem 15 11
und wir haben jetzt auch nach wie vor
sehen wir wieder dass die zahlen an
steigen auch die niedergelassene
ärzteschaft hat während der feiertage
oder zwischen den jahren auch fleißig
gewusst hat und wird jetzt auch wieder
noch mehr zulegen und das brauchen wir
auch weil eines ist heute auch noch
einmal sehr stark betont worden durch
die wissenschaft herr professor krömer
war ja als chef der ärztliche chef der
charité und mitglied einfach des
expertenrats heute auch wieder in der
sitzung gewesen hat berichtet eines ist
klar dass boost dann ist der beste
schutz gegen omikron und diejenigen die
einfach die dreifach impfung haben haben
zum einen die es die chance dass es sich
nicht anstecken zum anderen aber auf
jeden fall inzwischen nach allen
wissenschaftlichen studien die beste
chance wenn sie doch erkranken einen
sehr geringen oder sehr milden verlauf
zu haben wir haben vor allem zu kämpfen
mit einer sache nämlich sehr stark
ansteigenden instanzen und auf der
anderen seite wissen wir zwar inzwischen
nach vielen studien das comic on einen
milderen verlauf nimmt als erkrankung
das symptom ist schneller zeigen dass
sie kurz anhalten dass man auch
schneller wieder gesunden kann wir
wissen aber gleichzeitig auch durch
diese hohe infektiosität dass wir
einfach sehr sehr viele davon ausgehen
müssen dass ganz viele menschen in der
gesellschaft auch davon betroffen sein
werden und wir damit eben auch gerade in
der kritischen infrastruktur die gefahr
laufen dass viele menschen gleichzeitig
in deutschland einfach krank werden das
ist genau die feststellung des
expertenrats in der ersten stellungnahme
und es war ja auch der grund warum wir
alle in den bundesländern uns ist an die
arbeit gemacht haben auf die kritische
infrastruktur zu schauen das tun wir
auch in rheinland-pfalz wir tun das auch
regelmäßig das heißt wir überprüfen
unsere kritische infrastruktur stetig
und sie wird auch ständig überwacht
unser krisenstab befasst sich zweimal
die woche mit diesem thema um genau zu
beobachten
wie steht die kritische infrastruktur
insgesamt da und wie werden notfallpläne
aktiviert
wie ist die aktuelle situation und wie
können wir die aktuelle situation eben
auch immer anpassen um an ende sagen zu
können polizei feuerwehr rettungsdienste
was kritische infrastruktur
krankenhäuser selbstverständlich unsere
schulen dass wir die notfall und die
hygienepläne so umsetzen dass wir eben
auch frühzeitig probleme erkennen können
und gegensteuern können die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
hat sich auch entschieden entsprechende
quarantäne regelungen zu verkürzen das
hat zum einen den hintergrund dass
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
uns deutlich machen dass man davon
ausgehen kann dass das medizinisch sehr
gut vertretbar ist dass man es mache
einfach weil der verlauf von omikron ein
anderer ist zum anderen dadurch
sichergestellt dass eben nicht so viele
bürger und bürgerinnen gleichzeitig in
der isolation sind oder in der
quarantäne sind und wir damit einfach
auf das gesellschaftliche leben besser
aufrechterhalten können
soweit zur bund länder konferenz war den
corona maßnahmen und den ergebnissen die
jetzt in die umsetzung gehen dankeschön
für ihre aufmerksamkeit meine damen und
herren das ist für uns alle sehr wichtig
deshalb auch der wunsch ein see bleiben
sie bitte gesund und passen sie auf sich
und auf die anderen auf